next up is Bern Alan's gonna tell us
about it cool debt reductions so I'm
going to talk about syntactically multi
linear circuits which I realize nobody
has spoken about so I'll start by
defining them so these are arithmetic
circuits with the following property ok
so so let me start by defining
syntactically multi linear circuits so
these are arithmetic circuits where
product gates have the following
property if you look at that the sub
circuits rooted on the children
they do not share a common variable so
so we use this notation throughout the
talk so we'll have G G 1 G 2 the set of
variables that the that the sub-circuits
of the children depend on they are
disjoint but at the addition gates they
can share variable so it's a circuit
it's not really a formula and these are
sort of natural ish models and they're
fairly well studied the reason they're
natural ish is because many of the
polynomial families of interest for us
are actually multilinear the
determinants in the permanent the
iterated matrix multiplication
elementary symmetric polynomials and so
on and if you try to come up with a
circuit for them by yourself very likely
the circuit that you would come up with
would actually have this property
because if you do multiply if the
children do intersect and you do compute
non multi linear things then there is
some cancellation to happen for the
final computation typically we don't
know how to do this a well-known
exception to this is the determinant for
the determinant polynomial we know poly
n sized circuits which are highly non
multi linear we don't know syntactically
multi linear circuits for the
determinant and we probably also don't
expect determinants to have such
circuits even though we don't have any
lower actually n I don't know anything
non-trivial for the determinant which is
syntactic ultimately
but but they have been studied
nevertheless so it started with this
paper of avi and norm nice on from my DS
well they define something which looked
like this and proved some lower bounds
for it but but the but the real
important results happened in the decade
after that where
it's a rise fruit formula lower bounds
it's a super polynomial formula lower
bounds were syntactically multi-linear
formulas and this was followed up by a
bunch of papers of Ron and Amir where
they proved an exponential lower bound
for constant depth formulas practically
multi linear and we will look at what
this result is and this would be
important for us unbounded fanon and for
what it's worth we know better lower
bounds for syntactically multi linear
circuits than no no for general circuits
so this was a result of an Amir and Omid
and then recently with Naga alone and
Ben Lee we improved it so we know n to
the 2 minus Epsilon so what we know for
them is a little bit better than what we
know in general which is which is not so
much in any case okay so so what would
be of interest for us would be this
particular lower bound
and what presented a offshored was the
following so they showed that there is
an explicit family of polynomials the
degree of any formula depth for
syntactically multi linear circuit pn n
to the omega square root of n over log
and the result is more generally it
holds for formulas of arbitrary boundary
depth and the bound decays appropriately
maybe we'll come to it later and when we
started working on this what we wanted
to do was to improve this bound to
better bounds better lower bounds for
this and if you if you have seen these
kind of theorems for lower bounds for
depth for circuits at some points lower
bounds for depth for circuits do start
implying general circuit lower bounds so
in particular if you prove strong enough
lower bounds for depth for syntactically
multi linear circuits it would imply
lower bounds or unbounded depths and
tactically multi linear circuits but it
seemed that this number this bound in
the current state was a little bit far
from where lower bounds imply general
circuit lower bounds so
the debt reduction results say the
following n to the little Omega square
root D
so so even though these results are
proved for general homogeneous circuits
if you follow through the proof these
results actually hold for syntactically
multi linear circuits and so on so in
particular for a degree n polynomial if
we had lower bounds which were better
than n to the root n then we would have
the under 30 lower bounds right so the
same kind so syntactically multi linear
circuit no super Polly okay so for a
while the plan for us was to at least
get rid of the login factors in the in
these lower bounds and maybe nothing
spectacular happens and we couldn't do
that and the main theorem here is that
this result can be tightened for
syntactically multi linear circuits
I'm in the following so P is a
polynomial is a polynomial computed by a
syntactically multilinear circuit s
this implies that P can be computed by
syntactically multilinear for circuit
as to the order of square root of n over
log and so you should think of s as poly
n so this is n to the root of n over log
n so here n is the number of variables
so right so right so this bound so so
what happens as the degree varies so if
degree is much smaller than n over log
in then this is actually a better bound
the the natural the the usual depth
reduction results of a Gravina with
these new parameters by Sebastian are
the better ground so n to the root D is
a smaller number and n to the square
root of n over log n but the moment
degree becomes large then this is a
better Brown multi linear polynomial so
degree can be at most n so but if the
degree becomes larger than n over log
and then there's a better bound and it
it matches this lower bound and it turns
out so in this paper they proved this
lower bound for a polynomial which has a
which has a unbounded depth
syntactically multi linear circuit of
size poly a syntactic linear means it
means this that every product gate the
children depend on to join sets of
variables so so so in that sense this is
also the right bound
a general reduction from my suspicion of
criminal not that I know of
we don't even know a reduction from a
semantically multilinear circuit to a
syntactically materially new circuits or
beyond were taken semantically
multilinear you impose the semantic
construction restriction that at every
gate in the circuit you are computing a
multi linear polynomial this is sort of
a syntactic restriction on the structure
of the circuit not the computation that
good okay so so that was a result so
I'll say a bit more about this but
questions so far in the sense of the
previous ones right you just show it
existence by chopping yeah all right no
all the depth reduction results are
actually constructive pretty much so you
could so the reason I'm asking this you
get a black box the kind of black box
reduction for the lower bounds in the
pis I think because they are not
constructive right so okay so I didn't
follow the question but I think the
lower bounds are one could do it by hand
somebody had given a circuit you can
construct the reducer yeah and this is
true for the general in the usual depth
reduction results also there is a reason
why you cannot supply monthly box
heating no black box Paet from right I
love to think I know there's a reason
I'll have to think about it but I can do
this off so questions so far so let me
tell you a little bit more about what
really happens here
so this reduction is also a little bit
more general than then what's written
here so it doesn't just hold for
syntactically multilinear circuit it
also holds for circuits where you're not
allowed to take very high powers of
variables so circuits are so-called
individual degree as most K so if you
start from a circuit of individual
degree at most K the bound that you get
is as to the order of square root of n K
over log so this will also satisfy the
the reduced circuit will have the
property also this depth for circuit has
a little bit more structure than and
just the size being this so the depth
for circuit that you get is of the form
sum over I so so I goes from 1 to this
bound of s to the order and actually
depends on n login variables
in particular its degree is bounded by
square root of n log n but there's more
it just doesn't see too many variables
none of the queue is actually seems a
lot
okay questions of
so let me say something about the proof
so the proof is like a typical depth
reduction result in the non multi linear
setting there will be two steps we'll
start from a size s in tactically multi
linear circuit in the first step
constructor call a balanced I'll tell
you what it is but the size blow up in
this step will only be poly s the next
step they go from the balanced circuit
to a depth water now the size blow up
will be
let me say a bit about what a balanced
circuit is
so balanced circuit has will have the
following property the circuit that you
construct there so the some fan in to
think of this as unbounded so it would
be some some fan and will be unbounded
product Fannin's will be bounded by a
constant Phi for instance and every
product gate will have the following
property it will have five children
and if you look at the degree of the so
let's say this is zero not g1 up to if
you look at the number of variables in
you
number of variables in any of the
children it's going to be at most of the
number of variables in you so it means
that none of the product gates you you
incur a so they're not very skewed so
each of the children is is roughly much
much smaller roughly half the weight of
the parent and if you have seen the
usual debt reduction results then there
is a notion very similar to this that
appears there where the right notion
turns out to be the degree this is what
happens in for instance this work of
ESBL
so in some sense you could think of it
as the potential function that we are
working with changes from the degree of
a polynomial the degree of a gate to the
number of variables in it
and if you want to work with circuits
with bounded individual degree which was
the other statement I mentioned there
then you have to change it appropriately
yes scale pretty much you just scared by
the constant degree like the number of I
was just cut out like that book out then
what happened okay or something like
that yeah yeah it's something like that
so you have to look at the exponent
vector and it's yeah yeah so the depth
here will be so since it's unbounded
some fan in the depth you can bound it
by like order log N or the log S
and so in the so the first step we go
from a general circuit to a balanced
circuit and that incurs a poly blow-up
but Polly and Polly s blow but we have
this additional structure in the next
step we go from a balanced circuit to a
depth four circuit and the gain that you
get is is actually visible in this step
so I will show you that
a balanced way we do it is is the
following so inaccurately in a picture
the way we depict it would be that will
will make a cut in the circuit so we
will collect all the gates all gates
square root of n log and variables
and then we'll view these gates as sort
of input gates and you view the
computation that's happening on top on
these gates so since the circuit is
balanced it turns out that the top
computation the degree of the top is
actually small and also it will satisfy
this syntactically multilinear structure
so now this this immediately gives the
way of writing a depth for circuit so
for the top part we'll just write it as
a sum of monomials and in the bottom
part we have these gates which depend on
a small number of variables so we'll
write all of them again as a sum of
monomials now the point is that the top
has small degree so the size would be at
most its so it's a small degree
polynomial on at most s variables so the
size would be s to the order of n log N
and the bottom part you are looking at
multilinear polynomials on square root
of n log n variables so the size would
be at most to the square root of n
that's espalier and they balance out so
it's a bit different from what happens
in general where the this big cut here
is defined in terms of the degree so you
pick the degree to be something degree K
the top part will have degree about D
over K so you get a s to the D over K
bound here you get a n to the K bound
here because you're looking at
polynomials of degree at most K and then
you balance n to the K and n to the D
over K and the right threshold turns out
to be K being square would be here you
are trying to balance s to the n over K
and 2 to the K so the right threshold
turns out to be square root of n log
patients on this workshop why will the
outer semester so it's a it's a
polynomial of degree square root of n
over log in on at most s variables
you're right
all right so so this is really where the
game comes from this is also tight like
I said because of yeah because of Amir
and runs through that so we know that we
can't hope for a general theorem of this
form where I I can put something little
o for little of this quantity here
okay
so well if you want to get polynomial
over balance for synthetic people doing
your circuits yeah this is basically
nothing so there's some game in the in
the constants which appear here yeah but
this constant is not too bad it's like
10 but it's bad enough if you want to
prove n to the 10 lower bound then seems
unlikely that this is the way - okay
like 5 minutes so I want to tell you
something about how this is true
I was hoping that I wouldn't have time
left for this so here's the the idea is
the following so if you have seen how
the usual depth reduction proofs of ESP
are work so valiant scheme Berkowitz and
Rakoff so this is like that but with
some crucial differences that made it
interesting
so the key definitions there is the
notion of a quotient and what's called a
frontier decomposition so it's a bit
hard to justify why this is the right
definition to look for but I will define
the quotients don't ask me why that's
the right definition so for every two
gates in the circuit the u comma V will
define the quotient of U with respect to
V and it's inductively defined so so if
u is equal to V then the quotient is 1 U
is a sum the quotient is the sum of the
quotient
so before I define the next one will
follow this will follow this this
assumption that at every product gate
the number of variables in the right
child is heavier than the number of
variables in the left child so it's it's
a right heavy this is really without
loss of generality it's just a
relabeling so the product gate things
are asymmetric the quotient is
asymmetrically defined and lastly if V
is ul times so this is the polynomial
computer that you will okay so this is
the polynomial computer data gate CL is
the question with respect to the right
child and if B is not in the circuit you
then the quotient is zero okay so this
is a definition the reason this comes in
handy is the following
so the balanced circuit that is
eventually constructed you you will have
gates for all you will have a gate for
all the gates in the original circuit
and all the quotients of two possible
gates so for all pairs even be there's a
gate there which computes the quotient
of und does not have a path to be and
the reason this is an interesting
definition is because of what happens
here so there's a notion of frontier so
so F sub M is the set of all so in in
the case of Valiant at all's proof this
is the set of all gates such that if you
look at the degree of U it's larger than
its at least m and both the children
have degree strictly smaller than F so
in some sense when you are going
bottom-up in the circuit this is the
first time when the degree actually
becomes larger and in our case so one of
the differences in our proof and the
earlier proof was that the the frontiers
in in vs beers proof were always defined
with respect to gates so degree was the
potential function and the degree could
only grow at multiplication gates so
your frontiers will only be
multiplication gates but in our case we
will define we work with number of
variables as or potential function and
number of variables can also change at
summation gates and in a homogeneous
circuit degree remains the same as
summation unit so in our case our
frontiers are defined with respect to
edges
so an edge is a frontier edge if the
number of variables here is larger than
M and the number of variables here is
strictly smaller than n and this
summation the these these edges could
have all sorts of gates here they could
be summation they could be
multiplication so this complicates the
structure of what how the number of
variable evolves over a period of time
and this messes around with what the
frontier decomposition really looks like
so I'll just write an equation and stop
with it
we'll have two kinds of frontières will
have summation gates edges where the top
is a summation gate and multiplication
gates and so if you take u such that X
sub u is larger than M then you can
write the polynomial computed at you so
these are edges in the in the
multiplicative frontiers these are edges
in this in the frontiers with that the
top gate is a some gate and there are
two kinds of terms there are
contributions from these guys there are
contributions from these guys if you
look at the usual the valiant at all
proof this second term is absent the
first term roughly looks like this so
there's some error term which has to be
taken care of in the decompositions and
roughly the way you build a balanced
circuit is you inductively build
circuits for these guys and then you
write this guy as a sum of product of
these things and try to works out ok so
that's all
wishes
okay can you can I to get the festive oh
boy it's like this better than one
I don't know how to do that
okay thanks for making it
[Applause]